tonight I meet r2d2 tom has his first
popcorn and I get served by a before
Claus
we came back at breakfast at the diner
this is a lazy day we haven't really got
a huge amount lined out on a day
yesterday was pretty intense
it was quiet do you know with people
from accident and okay I've received a
piece of information which has
completely changed all the plans for the
day on Twitter pictures just appeared
the r2d2 himself is in the exhibition
hall and my life's not complete without
a picture or a video with r2d2 so guess
where I'm going I'm coming to you mr. D
- I just heard him I can hear our CDC
where is he
oh my god
oh my god
mr. D - bubbles with more line work in
the James Avery
currently that actually has happens just
your pictures of me dd-do
so I just sat down and basically didn't
productive I was catching up on YouTube
subscriptions in emails but I'm not the
only one who's not being productive
because people are dropping well we
found this easier as well that by the
end of the week people are just getting
really tired so people were just napping
and that we've given them a standard
till midnight to our Star Wars it's just
kind of funny really everyone just runs
out of steam so I'm in the big ballroom
ahead of the front is og a physics
lecture got a nice and a leaf receipt
and it turns out I needn't worry because
there's about one and a half houses fast
seat but yeah it's nice this is the room
that we went in for the other day for
Elon Musk and for the X prizes tour you
can see it's huge I just learned the
capacities actually 1/2 thousand people
so I was actually pretty close decide
where to sit now I didn't want to sit at
the front because I think other people
deserve that more than me it seems good
today anyway I'd like to what I'm going
to talk about is the role of geosciences
and understanding our system structure
so we just got out of the - that was the
Geoscience future juice trivia so
geophysics basically in America so that
was all about how we're basically like
science is often thought as being very
different you know it's like separate
from most of society and it's than a
research institutes and universities and
then the effect kind of like trickle
down but in the case of geosciences
particularly now you know in which of
our global warming those effects need to
be felt you know about you know soon as
I felt the better way so well that's the
lecture was all about it was a very
interesting lecture all about how there
are lots of intergovernmental
organizations the UN FCC is one of them
so you're Nestor the UNFCCC the IPCC are
just too you know to them there are
loads of organizations that are looking
at climate risks extreme events flooding
food shortages population crises you
know like a huge number of organizations
that was one point and to that they're
doing a lot of work already three that
there's one phase but coming to an end
and others about to begin and that the
work is gonna be more and more important
as time goes on really but it is it's
it's great to see that like instead of
there being like a percolation down of
the offensive science this is a direct
scientists talking to heads of state
local community leaders and making the
effects felt it was the only arguably
the most important thing that happens
yeah had this conference is that
interface between the Reeb the best
science in the world and then that being
fed strange society so for a very that
wasn't a poorly attended lecture this
was an amazing attender that was really
important but not as important as much
in a way it's a really nice experience
what control of these posters and not
having a bloody clue what any of them
mean
I mean I do mean an American sense I
mean that in the sense of um you do PhD
he's been so much time working on the
subject you exclusively work on you know
one small topic and you know that topic
inside the field inside you know you
know that mic because I know all the
essential parts of physics physics and
math central yeah I know
I'm gonna talk about physics
it's a nice feeling not knowing
so I just had a highly scientific
afternoon right over there is the a GU
cinema and for the past no couple of
hours
I was just sat in there on my laptop
writing two things up but watching a
whole bunch of short films so they could
they were changed short films for all
there's the conference and I've seen
Rory every single sin in producing short
films over the past couple of days in
addition to the comics and the other day
I think the thing which never noticed
most of all is the most I was almost
going to say most scientists most
scientists who produced these films are
not musicians because music is just it's
almost always wholly inappropriate over
the end credits and it's almost always
the kind of plinky funky guitar ukulele
thing now now we're going to go off to a
meal with all the extra people
we're a Mexican restaurant it's called
tacky era which leads me to believe is a
very low-quality mistake this looks like
this it's good the subscribe hunting but
it's closest Mexican food I'll eat
well that was fun when I win we're now a
mission we're in the Mac basically the
Mexican part of the city we're officers
find a bar before we go off to other
business you guys embarrassing the
parents by me yeah God stop tracking me
down this is the X - log you've met them
all by this point apart from Matt there
yet so we're we're a mission of a
graphite bar and they were gonna go
watch Star Wars this sounds like a
pretty much perfect
we found a street market so the barrio D
so we just had a really weird experience
Buddhists in this bar incidentally which
smells like San Francisco by which I
mean it smells
massively of weed these are jazz
musicians turned up and at the same time
the ride of the valkyries died playing
so of all the places I expected here
vogner a bar in San Francisco in the
Mexican district of San Francisco was
that was not one of them
so we've decided to vacate the bar as
soon as the music was about start smell
that we see balloon burning hair sighs
yeah they were just burning weed they
were blazing it yes it's amazing how
blase people are about it here but I
think it is legal worse basically so
it's basically smells like Amsterdam
dude which is saying something because
Amsterdam was quite a dank stench
we got the film it isn't a couple of
hours I don't know maybe we'll go back
to my hotel and just pre geek yes no no
it's like free drinking but your geek
okay I knew that was gonna be a lot of
interest like a lot of interest
oho jarhead
Jesus Christ help we're moving we're
leaving each house has convenient but
Kim is my really good lighting my
hearing to keep Starwood it is one it's
actually not for a decent Star Wars for
washing each other every single screen
in the earth upon to be dedicated
thank backlash well we've got the full
range of interests we got last year by
excited Tommy who hasn't seen any so it
made a noise like what although it
sounded like it was breaking that was it
was that was the one that they
originally picked and then they picked
r2 instead oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh yeah
look some some Trekkies are here we've
got we've got they've got Commander data
a commander Riker
they do drinks differently here we can
count on the first fly in the ointment
they only have this week I'll take soda
pop can have an air popcorn but
be honest if that's the biggest
discipline that I'll be very happy good
god this place has a good ungodly number
of screech oh my god this is actually
happening oh yeah of course I won't yeah
this is a lot of planning to get us
there
yeah you record that bit okay can I
interest you in a popcorn the time
what's the verdict I'm turning you on
and then afterwards we'll talk
it was a very good judgement until
tomorrow
now that layer between 10 kilometers and
50 kilometers now Stube is what we call
the stratosphere and it accounts for
almost the entirety of the remaining
mass of the atmosphere see ya let's see
if I can remember this or if you want
more videos with John and I just talking
about stuff then please comment below
make sure you go and look at that
singing playlist of choral music about
Christmas comment below which one piece
is your favorite you know just have a
listen to a few and shuffle